bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport il est 18h36 vous nous suivez en
direct c'est parti comme tous les lundis
pour un nouveau tour de l'actu sport du
département en 26 minutes tremblement de
terre à l'Étoile Sportive de Trappes le
président Mustapha Larbaoui a donné sa
démission il y a quelques jours après 8
ans de service il va nous donner les
explications de cette décision le vélo
drone de 50 ans en Yvelines a accueilli
ce week-end sa toute première
compétition officielle la coupe d'hiver
de quoi détecter les talents de demain
et préparer la saison hivernale pour la
deuxième année consécutive la course du
soleil s'élancera des Yvelines l'édition
2014 du Paris-Nice partira de
Mantes-la-Jolie et fera étape à
Rambouillet et évidemment prendre des
missions comme d'habitude tous les
résultats du week-end
mais tout d'abord on passe au sport
mécanique et aux raid du 4L Trophy et
édition 2014
Benoît et Martin bonjour à tous les deux
merci de nous accueillir dans ce garage
dédié aux voitures anciennes c'est ici
que vous préparez votre véhicule pour la
17e édition du 4L Trophy Sorede
humanitaire on le rappellerait aux
étudiants et long de 6000 km qui
traverse la France l'Espagne et le Maroc
tout d'abord première question comment
est née votre projet de participation à
ce raid Benoît
c'est un projet qui est né il y a à peu
près un an on est tous les deux dans la
même école non école de commerce et
voilà c'était un projet donc qu'on
nourissait depuis plusieurs années et
puis cette année c'est présenté
l'opportunité d'y participer pour tous
les deux donc voilà on a surtout que
l'année prochaine en fait on va avoir un
stage de fin d'étude c'est la fin des
cours ça y est ça approche du coup là
c'était vraiment la dernière opportunité
puisque comme vous l'avez dit en
introduction on a besoin d'être étudiant
pour le raid donc c'était l'occasion ou
jamais voilà il y avait chez vous le
besoin de vivre quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ensemble partir loin de
des bases Versailles et vinoise pour
vivre quelque chose ensemble oui c'est
ça exactement fait le côté à la fois
sportif et puis le pôle aventure on se
dit à la fois le 4L est connu mais en
même temps en fait moi j'y connaissais
rien spécialement de comment ça se passe
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire 6000 km à deux
dans une petite voiture puis en fait bah
c'est le voilà c'est c'est génial
d'avoir cette opportunité donc d'où
notre présence aujourd'hui le départ
c'est le 13 février donc dans quelques
jours quand on est arrivé il y avait
encore quelques petits réglages que j'ai
remarqué sur le véhicule vous finissez
la préparation en ce moment même
absolument puisqu'en fait le gros a déjà
été fait là au niveau mécanique
justement au garage mais il reste
toujours des petits trucs des petits
cols matages un petit coup de colle là
notamment on a les essuie-glaces à
changer encore quand on arrivait
pleuvait et c'était pas terrible donc ça
reste un petit truc à changer voilà on
sait que les 4L ce sont des châssis
assez anciens il y a eu des problèmes de
de tout simplement mécanique pendant la
préparation Benoît alors on a eu la
chance de pas avoir de problème au
niveau du châssis il y a pas mal de 4L
qui sont refusés au parce que leur
châssis est en trop mauvais état nous
notre châssis est sain mais bon on a
toujours quelques petits préparations à
faire il a fallu qu'on mette des plaques
de blindage sous la voiture parce
qu'elle n'y était pas on a changé tout
l'allumage on a changé d'autres pièces
très importantes pour un 4L Trophy oui
pour se protéger notamment un des chocs
dans le désert vous êtes un peu
passionné de mécanique à la base ou vous
apprenez un petit peu en serrant les
boulons là depuis quelques semaines
alors pour ma part non absolument pas je
suis pas un grand passionné de mécanique
mais bon c'est quelque chose qui qui
m'intéresse je trouve ça sympa et puis
on apprend pas mal oui en bricolant en
cherchant et en trouvant et de votre
côté alors niveau mécanique mécanique
pur non j'avoue franchement là je
découvre voiture oui je souhaite un
grand passionné de voiture ça c'est
clair mécanique là je oui il y a tout à
apprendre je pense être un peu calé en
fait 0 la bulle complète mais c'est
l'occasion d'apprendre donc c'est vous
lisiez un raid c'est jamais parfait il y
a toujours des petits ennuis mécaniques
qui va faire le mécanicien au milieu du
désert
les deux on est une équipe de deux donc
on va s'y mettre à deux mais donc voilà
il y a pas de il y a pas de pilote
copilote pour l'instant dans ces chacun
son tour pilote copilote
alors dans ce rêve il y a aussi
évidemment l'aspect humanitaire qui qui
compte beaucoup dans le 4L Trophy
expliquez-nous un petit peu justement
les enjeux avec combien de denrées par
exemple vous devez partir et qu'est-ce
que vous emmenez alors chaque équipage
part avec environ entre 30 et 50 kg de
fournitures scolaires à destination des
enfants les plus démunis du Maroc donc
c'est une opération qui est menée avec
l'association Enfants du Désert donc
voilà donc au total cette année on sera
plus de 1300 équipages donc je vous
laisse calculer le nombre de kilos que
ça va faire à l'arrivée c'est un
rendez-vous que vous attendez justement
cette rencontre peut-être qu'il y aura
peut-être des enfants marocains qui
attendront impatiemment toutes vos
fournitures non oui c'est ça bah en fait
à la fois il faudra faire attention
puisque l'organisation précise bien
quand on traverse des villages ils sont
ils sont prévenus au niveau de
l'organisation mais évidemment ça
n'empêche pas de faire des arrêts tout
au long du Trophy et puis après à
l'arrivée puisque l'essentiel du
matériel qu'on apporte se fait au
village à l'arrivée où là le gros du
matériel est déposé raide veut dire
compétition va quand même un petit peu
en parler il y a un objectif de
classement pour votre tout premier aide
à tous les deux ou pas ou c'est vraiment
le plaisir et la découverte alors on y
va tout d'abord pour le plaisir et pour
la découverte pour l'expérience que ça
représente ensuite au niveau du
classement bon on a quand même voilà on
aimerait bien être plutôt bien
positionné voilà alors votre budget à
voisine à peu près les 8000 euros j'ai
regardé ça de près cela a été un
parcours du combattant pour le réunir ce
budget on sait que c'est c'est pas
facile économiquement en ce moment ça a
été difficile effectivement en fait on a
avec Benoît on a on a démarré en fait en
amont par les grands groupes les grandes
entreprises en fait on a été on a vu des
chanter c'est assez difficile puisqu'en
fait
c'est un trop petit budget pour que ça
puisse réellement intéresser les grands
groupes du coup c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est ensuite dirigé vers les
commerçants locaux ce qui en fait est
beaucoup plus pas puisqu'on a contact
avec les gens on se voit directement il
y a un impact réel quand quelqu'un donne
2-300 euros pour un encart c'est concret
alors qu'une grande entreprise au final
fait de la pub partout ailleurs donc ça
c'était un point très positif mais
difficile c'est vrai très bien vous
ferez donc partie vous le disiez tout à
l'heure Benoît des 1300 équipages à
partir du 13 février prochain dans
quelques jours de ce gigantesque peloton
qui traversera donc la France l'Espagne
et le Maroc bonne route à vous
destination Marrakech merci beaucoup à
tous
quant à moi je vous propose un coup de
projecteur sur ce lieu atypique ce
garage qui redonne vie aux voitures
anciennes et les ferrennes du macadam
images de Jonathan Willeman et Étienne
Dang
Christian neyrol délivre ses derniers
conseils à cet équipage du 4L Trophy
2014 a tout juste 200 000 km le véhicule
de Martin et Benoît va participer à son
second raid autant dire qu'il faudra
savoir réagir au moindre problème
mécanique au milieu du désert un peu
perdu sous le capot ces deux yvelinois
sont venus dans ce garage saint-cyrien
pour apprendre le B à bas de la clé à
molette
des mécaniciens voilà je leur apprends
simplement à anticiper les pannes et
intervenir sur certaines petites pannes
au niveau de l'allumage carburation
et des trains roulants voilà
ceci dit lorsqu'il est en joint de
culasse ou une distribution qui lâche
ils ne sont pas aptes à le faire très
peu
christianneyrol a ouvert cet atelier il
y a quatre ans et depuis il passe ses
journées sous les capots de ces vieilles
dames des années 50 pour leur donner une
seconde vie sur le macadam contrairement
aux véhicules modernes avec une 4 une
Simca ou encore une 504 nul besoin
d'ordinateurs de bord un retour aux
racines de la mécanique qui connaît un
grand succès il y a de plus en plus de
demandes ça c'est démocratisé de par le
fait que les véhicules des années 60
sont beaucoup plus facile à rouler et
entretenir que les véhicules les années
40 30 donc il y a un mouvement qui s'est
créé depuis quelques années et en ce qui
concerne les dauphines les 403 les deux
chevaux les 4L il y a un engouement
particulier pour ces véhicules de leur
côté Martin et Benoit espèrent avoir
toutes les clés pour ramener leurs 4L du
Maroc sur ces quatre roues
après 10 ans de service le président de
l'Étoile Sportive de Trappa donner sa
démission il y a quelques jours Mustapha
Larbaoui bonsoir vous êtes présent sur
le plateau du 7 8 sport on va le dernier
match en quelques sortes tout d'abord
pourquoi avoir décidé de vous retirer la
présidence alors pour une raison très
simple c'est que je ne peux plus
travailler tout simplement
sur quel domaine de votre de votre
fonction c'est par rapport au système
interne du club le fonctionnement
interne ou d'autres conflits viennent en
ligne de compte alors pour que les
spectateurs comprennent bien c'est que
un club de foot de cette de cette
dimension je rappelle quand même 900
licenciés à peu près donc c'est autant
de personnes à côté ce qui veut dire
quasiment le double de personnes
concernées par le par le club avec les
parents et les enfants
ça nécessite une congestion
tout le monde comprendra bien que une
entreprise comme celle-ci une entreprise
humaine
fonctionne à la fois avec des moyens
techniques
donc des terrains de foot des terrains
de foot qui soit à la fois
en capacité de recevoir ceux qui
pratiquent mais en même temps pour la
sécurité or de ça dont il s'agit je ne
suis plus un truc à moi sachant que ce
soir je suis là pour représenter la
présidence donc c'est pas ma personne en
l'occurrence dont je voudrais parler ce
soir mais bien du club et des 900
licenciés la sécurité je considère
qu'elle n'est elle est elle est pas
compromise le mot est un peu fort mais
je crois qu'on a il y a du travail à
faire encore en terme de sécurisation
vous voulez dire par là que les terrains
ne permettent plus de jouer sereinement
alors actuelle à trappe c'est ça que
vous entendez on sait clairement pour
que tout le monde comprenne bien
on sait rétracté sur très peu de
terrains qui eux sont bien évidemment
pour l'avoir vérifié avec tous les
éducateurs sur très peu de terrains qui
permettent de travailler en sécurité
donc ce sur lequel on travaille on va
dire pour faire simple 3
le quatrième étant réservé au match du
dimanche et quand les intempéries le
permettent nous sommes maintenant sur
trois pelouses sécurisées sur un total
de 8 terrains à peu près sur un total de
l'ensemble de la communauté et j'engage
les journalistes à faire effectivement
un voyage sur la commune dont deux en
friche et deux noms non non jouables en
l'occurrence si on veut travailler
sérieusement et en termes de sécurité
donc oui je considère qu'on est on est
sur trop trop peu de terrain pour
assumer à la fois le travail qu'on a
assumé le nombre donc c'est la qualité
et la quantité
et voilà donc
j'alerté depuis maintenant quelques
quelques années c'est pas une décision
qui est prise à la légère je ne pars pas
ce soir comme on peut le prétendre de
façon excitée j'ai un tempérament j'ai
des choses à dire je peux lui dire de
différentes manières mais en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui
je considère que je peux pas travailler
mais ça fait des années que j'allaiste
ça fait des années que je le dis on
connaît votre pubnacité vous êtes réputé
pour ça sur 50 ans en Yvelines votre
passion pour le football également on
peut pas croire que vous arrêtez vous
allez vous arrêter là dans à la fin de
la saison parce que vous allez continuer
la transition pour la fin de saison
juste entre guillemets pour un problème
de terrain quand même Mustapha Ben
écoutez c'est pas un problème de terrain
c'est un problème de relation avec le la
cogestion un problème de copilotage
c'est une très grosse entreprise encore
une fois entreprise humaine
non c'est pas un problème de terrain je
pense que c'est symptomatique j'avais
trouvé une solution
qui était une solution extrêmement
simple pour pour les habitants de
Trappes pour les habitants de La
Verrière une convention que je voulais
signer entre le club de gré à gré entre
le club et la commune j'ai commencé à
travailler sur le sujet en octobre j'ai
finalisé le courrier parce qu'on m'a
donné le feu vert de la commune de
trappes de la commune de La Verrière le
courrier date du 23 décembre aujourd'hui
nous sommes le 9 février j'ai pas un
coup de fil
de qui que ce soit pour me dire venez
signer c'est une solution qui permet de
jouer qui me permet de travailler et qui
coûte absolument absolument rien à nos
trappiste et
membre de la casqui pour parler de la
caisse qui donc voilà une solution
simple il y a un blocage je sais pas où
il est vous la poserez la question à eux
donc c'est pas un problème de terrain
c'est un problème de cogestion et moi je
considère qu'on est deux il y a les
subventions d'une part et puis il y a
les équipements moi avec mes troupes en
l'occurrence tous les guillemets que je
mets aux troupes mes éducateurs mes amis
les passionnés du foot les gens que
j'aime avec qui j'ai travaillé jusqu'à
maintenant on a fait notre part du
boulot on est deux voilà donc c'est pas
un problème de terrain non c'est un
problème de voilà c'est un problème pour
parler des terrains le stade Champsac
notamment et va être bientôt en travaux
des rénovations ça montre quand même que
la mairie essaie de faire des efforts
sur la situation de ces terrains qui
vous permettez si vous me permettez
d'abord critique rien c'est pas une
critique c'est juste des des faits que
vous pouvez vérifier on dit partout qui
a 8 terrains je vous en avez pardon je
vous en annonce 3 à vérifier
concrètement et les Trappistes qui
m'écoutent ce soir pour en vérifier
aisément et surtout ceux qui travaillent
ce que vous dites encore une fois je
voudrais le préciser c'est pas des
travaux sur Champsac pour le foot
sur les travaux sur Champsac pour
l'athlétisme donc on ferme pour des
problèmes de travaux pour éviter qu'il y
ait des incidents durant les travaux je
vais déménager pour pour des problèmes
de sécurité mais encore une fois ce
n'est pas pour le foot on refait la
notre chansac on refait la main courante
pour chanzac on refait des travaux pour
d'autres sports et j'en suis très très
heureux pour eux c'est pas pour le foot
et combien même on bouge nous au mois
d'avril on bougerait même pour nous ça
serait de l'anticipation que d'aller à
la verrière bien avant le championnat il
tourne le championnat il a commencé il a
repris aussi janvier et l'adaptation à
un terrain ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain donc on aurait pu commencer en
prévision de ces travaux Mustapha avec
cette démission Vous avez vous n'avez
pas l'impression d'abandonner c'est 900
licenciés un petit peu quand même au
cours d'un mandat non je pense que nous
avons été abandonnés j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir été abandonné et en l'occurrence
c'est pas ma personne qui était
abandonnée mais c'est c'est le club il y
a travers de la personne oui tous les
gens il y a un abandon un abandon de la
mairie concernant ce sport on pourrait
même parler d'autres sports à Trappes ou
il y a des mêmes soucis mais j'en
parlerai pas ici simplement non
j'abandonne rien c'est juste qu'il y a
un combat que je veux pas mener parce
que je suis face à un mur je ne vais pas
mener un combat contre mon père mon père
et légitime il est élu certainement
réélu non j'ai pas de combat à mener en
l'occurrence c'est une démission je ne
mènerai pas ce combat je le laisse à
d'autres je par contre je précise je
partirai pas comme ça on est bien
d'accord jusqu'à fin juin on a le temps
de travailler et de préparer la
transition cette démission vous savez
que vous représentez quand même beaucoup
sur la commune de Trappes cette
démission à un mois et demi on est
obligé d'en parler quand même du premier
tour de ces élections municipales qui
vont peut-être être très importante sur
cette commune elle est pour le moins
surprenante non on va pas vous retrouver
sur une liste plus tard dans quelques
semaines dites-nous c'est quand même
strictement sportif cette décision
Mustapha
vous le verrez c'est à dire vous le
verrez
j'avais dit Homer que je ne ferai jamais
de politique je crois même l'avoir
entendu avant d'arriver ici que je ne
ferai pas de politique sauf Aldi au
premier magistrat de cette ville donc
c'est à lui que je le dirai comme j'ai
toujours tenu mes promesses donc c'est à
lui que je le dirai sachant qu'il y
avait
Othman Nasro un des candidats aux
élections municipales qui étaient à
votre peau d'adieu en tout cas votre au
revoir hier soir il y avait quelques
prétendants
encore une fois c'était une réunion qui
n'était pas prévue dans ce sens merci de
me donner l'occasion de le dire c'est
qu'on avait prévu cette réunion
uniquement pour mes éducateurs et puis
comme les terrains sont fermés toute la
semaine j'ai ajouté mes seigneurs ce qui
a fait du monde et ce qui fait du monde
fait du bruit fait du buzz comme on dit
et donc je me suis retrouvé que beaucoup
plus de monde comme on le voit à la télé
maintenant c'était pas du tout prévu moi
je voulais faire une petite réunion très
intime avec mes éducateurs pour
l'expliquer et puis finalement comme les
terrains la preuve en est c'est que les
terrains on les avait pas on s'est
retrouvé beaucoup plus nombreux et
beaucoup plus nombreux ça a fait du ça
fait du buzz et l'information a circulé
on voit notre ami Nasro sur les images
et en fait il est venu pas du tout à mon
imitation parce que Luc miseren n'est
pas n'est pas là j'avais invité personne
sont venus ceux qui avaient envie de
venir non non n'y voyez pas de ma liste
encore une fois je suis pas à l'origine
du calendrier de cette affaire cette
réunion d'hier soir c'est encore une
fois les gens qui ont voulu être
nombreux pour me dire au revoir et le
calendrier c'est pas moi si on m'avait
donné mon terrain le 6 janvier je serai
pas aujourd'hui à vous dire je pars et
en l'occurrence avant les élections on
me laisse je serai parti avec ma lampe
torche je serais allé faire du du
football à La Verrière avec une lampe
torche dans le noir aujourd'hui on m'a
mis sur les projecteurs je suis pas bien
compris le message Mustapha merci
beaucoup bravo bravo sur le 7 8 sport et
encore merci à tous et on verra si vous
faites le buzz dans les prochaines
semaines merci beaucoup Mustapha on
passe au cyclisme cette semaine le
parcours de l'édition 2014 du Paris Nice
a été dévoilé par la Schmitt le
président du conseil général écrit sur
prud patron du cyclisme chez ASO et pour
la deuxième année consécutive la course
du soleil s'élancera du département plus
précisément pardon de la commune de
Mantes-la-Jolie images de Jonathan
Widman
pour la cinquième fois de son histoire
Paris Nice c'est lancera des Yvelines
l'édition 2014 de la course du soleil
partira de Mantes-la-Jolie pour une
première étape longue de 162 km avant de
retrouver la ville de Rambouillet le
département semble devenir la terre
promise du cyclisme pourtant le peloton
ne passera pas devant le vélo Drôme
national de 50 ans en Yvelines oui mais
on l'a beaucoup vu là pour
l'inauguration et puis il faut laisser
le temps je pense également à
l'équipement de ce rodé l'inauguration
d'une céleri elle est quelques jours bon
voilà il faut qu'il prenne j'adore son
rythme de croisière il y a encore des
aménagements intérieurs à achevé il y
aura toujours quelque chose de nouveau
dans le département des Yvelines dans le
domaine cyclisme indéniablement grâce à
cet outil performant
au cours de cette 72e édition il y aura
ni prologue ni contre-la-montre une
première depuis près de 60 ans 8 étapes
en ligne sont donc au programme qui
devrait sourire au baroudeur et au
punchers on souhaite que ce soit une
course ouverte avec des gens qui osent
et qui est une prime vraiment aux
audacieux c'est fait pour je suis bien
incapable de vous dire qui va gagner
parce que il n'y a pas les les
références classiques d'un chrono qui
permet aux favorise ce jauger ou d'une
arrivée classique en altitude il
n'existe pas non plus l'Australien
Richie Porte défendra son titre côté
Français Sylvain Chavanel 3e en 2009
aura toutes ses chances et les espoirs
Nasser boignés Brian Coquard viseront
certainement des victoires d'étapes
verdict à partir du 9 mars prochain
c'est l'information du week-end on rend
le requier regardez ce résultat il est
très important ils l'ont fait les chocs
d'Élancourt ont décroché leur toute
première victoire de la saison lors de
la dixième journée de Nationale de face
à Rouen succès 6 à 3 espérant qu'il en
appelle d'autres en football 19e journée
de Division d'Honneur Versailles c'est
incliné sur la pelouse de sa mort
Lusitanos de bu à zéro les joueurs de
David giguer rétrograde à la sixième
place à noter qu'en Promotion d'Honneur
les rencontres de trap aigu Guyancourt
ont été reportées en football féminin
12e journée de promotion d'honneur
Élancourt c'est incliné chez le
troisième Nicolette Chaillot des
Amazones conservent tout de même leur
sixième place ce week-end en cyclisme le
vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
accueillait sa toute première
compétition officielle la coupe d'hiver
de cyclisme sur piste se déroulant les
années précédentes à l'INSEP cet
événement réservé aux cycliste amateur
et organisé par le comité
d'Île-de-France est un moyen de repérer
les futurs talents de demain et aussi de
préparer la saison hivernale pour les
140 coureurs participants certains
étaient déjà venus en repérage quelques
jours auparavant pour découvrir cette
piste unique au monde et ça va sa
qualité semble séduire le plus tôt
je vais tester un entraînement j'ai
particulièrement aimé bien sûr parce
qu'elle est beaucoup plus large que les
c'est la plus large piste en Europe elle
fait 8 mètres je crois donc ça permet de
se lancer bien pour le pour l'esprit
elle est très roulante bien qu'elle soit
encore récente elle est très roulante
elle va se faire encore donc ça va
améliorer les performances et vraiment
non c'est vraiment un super outil
les professionnels les a sélection pour
les championnats du monde sur piste en
Colombie à Cali est tombé il y a
quelques jours et le nouvel alimenté en
François Pervis que vous voyez à l'image
champion du monde et recordman du monde
10 km et du 200 mètres tentera de
conserver sa couronne mondiale et
défendra aussi ses chances sur le kering
discipline dont il avait enlevé la
première manche de Coupe du monde à
Manchester en novembre dernier il sera
le pilier de l'équipe de France
évidemment Grégory Baugé de ce côté sera
aligné en vitesse par équipe pour son
retour au mondiaux en rugby 12 13e
journée d'honneur championnat
territorial et c'est malheureusement
toujours la même chanson dans la poule 2
pour le Sky rugby qui n'a pas pesé bien
lourd face à Cergy-Pontoise des fêtes 29
à 7 dans la poule 3 Rambouillet s'est
imposé dans le derbylinois face à
Montesson 20 à 3 en basket 17e journée
de Nationale une essaie toujours le même
sentiment de frustration qui domine les
féminines de l'Entente qui se sont une
nouvelle fois inclinée de cinq petits
points face au cinquième mot wasque 68 à
73 toujours pas de victoire pour les
joueuses Stéphane Rollet depuis plus de
trois mois et les 2 novembre dernier
chez les hommes 17e journée de Nationale
3 trappes 5 lignes sur son parquet face
à Rouen 65 à 83 de son côté le LCV
s'impose au Paris Levallois 82 à 76
emballe 13e journée de Nationale de fin
de série pour Montigny qui s'est incliné
à Ici Paris 25 21 les inintennes perte
une place au classement et se retrouve
cinquième elle n'avait plus perdu depuis
le 9 novembre dernier toujours du
handball chez les moins de 18 ans 4e
journée de la phase finale du
championnat de France plaisir enchaîne
avec une deuxième victoire consécutive
face à l'alliance Nord succès 30 à 24 le
plaisir roi reste troisième de leur
poule du volley-ball pour le compte de
la 10e journée de régional lune Montigny
recevait la lanterne rouge Clamart au
complexe de Coubertin les joueurs
d'Abdellatif Nishi prennent le match par
le bambou et ils font rapidement en fait
la course en tête dans le premier set
pour finalement le conclure sur cette
passe courte que vous avez eu 27 25 à 17
bis repetita dans la seconde manche les
inhymontins continuent pour leur lancer
bien aidés par une attaque performante
et une défense adverseuse à bois 25 17
également il boucleront l'affaire en
trois petits sets avec un 25 22 dans le
dernier acte avec cette victoire
Montigny remonte à la quatrième place au
classement général à 6 points du leader
Sartrouville une dernière info encore
deux infos à vrai dire du d'abord
d'abord du badminton le club des volants
d'Élancourt organisait son tournoi
national annuel ce week-end plus de 300
joueurs se sont affrontés sur les
terrains du Palais des Sports lors de
compétitions de doubles hommes femmes et
MX toujours très apprécié des Badis dans
ce format de match le rythmé beaucoup
plus rapide qu'en simple et surtout la
prise de repère dès les premiers points
est essentiel à la bonne performance de
l'équipe on écoute une équipe d'ailleurs
tendance à faire des amortis à jouer
tendu ou alors à dégager à dégager ou à
se matcher vu qu'on ne sait pas encore
bah on adopte les bases du double mixte
et ensuite on s'habitue assez le plus
rapidement possible du moins on essaye
au jeu de l'autre et ainsi on arrive à
signer se placer pour mieux
voilà pour mieux marquer le point après
une dernière info pas de course avant de
nous quitter ce vendredi lors de la 8e
soirée olympique du Comité Départemental
Olympique et Sportif des Yvelines
quelques athlètes 50 chinois ombriers
ont été récompensés comme les scrums de
Trappes Jérôme numéro 3 mondial chez les
juniors je le rappelle dans la catégorie
Espoir Féminin ainsi que ses
coéquipières de l'équipe féminine
récompensé également bravo à elle c'est
la fin de ce 7 8 sport merci encore une
fois de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
lundi prochain mais eux même meilleur
bonne soirée sur TV fils